okay I'd have to ask you about these
guys right here you are a father first
and foremost to win an NBA championship
with these two little guys right here
what's it like it's a real man I play
basketball to provide for these two has
been a long time coming yeah it's crazy
it's crazy right now
Papa's a young guy from North
Philadelphia North Philadelphia retinues
a North Philly who had all kinds of
questions about them not tall enough
not fast enough not athletic how does he
become an NBA champion hard work never
never saying anybody never let nobody
tell you can't do something special and
just a great group of guys man I
wouldn't be here for these guys or their
mother for these guys yeah I can't
really think right now this is crazy
it's awesome man Toronto Canada we
brought it home baby you brought home
Messiah
our leader across many categories but
Masai said that this championship wasn't
built in a year and is this process
unfolded you lost teammates one in
particular who I know you consider a
brother what would you say to demar
derozan I love him and I know he's happy
for me right now I'll FaceTime him later
but right now it's about us and
stanchion is about our fans and we don't
go celebrate some more right now you've
earned that as well congratulations Kyle
[Applause]